your character gives this fantastic line
in the film life is very fleeting it has
moments you should seize you know with
so much uncertainty this past year have
you had moments that you
appreciate more now than ever
yeah i mean i think i think family i
think time with family
um you know particularly now that we're
in lockdown and we can't see
um our family we can't see our friends i
think you know the times when we have
been
able to be together this year have been
so precious and
yeah and then not being able to be with
you know not being able to be with my
parents for christmas was
um you know you just miss those times
and i think
i can't wait to be able to just hug
everyone i know
i'm so excited i feel like that's
everyone's sentiment right now just want
to hug something as simple that you know
we used to do not think twice about
i know i know um you have such fantastic
chemistry with ray fines in this
were you able to hang out with them
beforehand or did that just come
naturally for you both on
set no yeah we were i mean we'd sort of
met a handful of times over the years
but we'd never sort of
really hung out and then i mean actually
i came to the job quite late notice as i
replaced someone
fairly last minute but we went
for lunch with john preston who wrote
the novel which the film's based on
um we had dinner with simon stone and
then we had sort of bits and pieces of
rehearsal and you know things in in the
run-up so i feel like
we got a good chance to to be
but he was you know he was very much
doing the accent by the time i got there
he was he stayed in the accent the whole
way through
um so it was kind of hard to separate
ray from basil in a way
you know because it was he was so
committed to this accident which i think
you know it's so difficult to do that
accent it's very specific
um and particularly when everyone around
you is doing sort of
upper class british accent which is what
we're all very used to i think he
he had to really sort of dig in to keep
that accent
oh i love that yeah no i mean he did
such a great job with that so yeah you
don't think it's difficult obviously but
it is
yeah yeah that's awesome um you know
this film you're so fantastic in um you
received fantastic reviews for promising
young woman
what does it mean for you to hear that
people are talking about an award season
run for you
i mean it's it's you know obviously just
really lovely you know just it's so nice
that people
enjoy the film i mean i think you know
more than anything what's so great about
award season is it does
shine a light on films that don't
necessarily aren't the sort of big
budget
blockbuster movies because we you know
promising young woman was made for a
really small budget
in 23 days and now it has this platform
because people are talking about it in
that
in that conversation and you know for
people to see emerald finnell's
work our director it's her first feature
film
you know she's made this amazing thing
and i think it's just given such a
yeah a platform for people to look at
that work and think like wow
yeah exciting um obviously with award
season this year we might not be seeing
red carpets so is that something that
you're looking forward to
that you don't have to kind of do all
the glitz and glams or will you miss out
of it
oh no i mean i i never thought i'd say
this because i've always made such a
fuss about how much i don't like red
carpets but for some reason now i think
it's so sad
i just want to wear it i'm going i'm
doing graham norton in a couple of weeks
and i'm just wearing a dress because i
just want to
you know i just want to sort of i mean i
haven't had an opportunity to dress up
for anything so i'm very excited about
it
um so i think it's a shame but you know
they've got to do what the safe thing is
and i'm sure they'll make the right
decisions but
um yeah you love it's so fun going
through scrolling through what
everyone's wearing
yeah you know part of the fun i love
that well your director simon also told
me that he put you guys through the
ringer
with all the rain coming down and it was
pretty cold and you had to pretend it
was summer so what was the whole filming
experience like for you
yeah it was a lot of pretending quite
hard but it was summer um
i mean in a way i was very lucky because
i you know because
i'm playing someone who's not in the
best health i was always
wearing a little bit more than everyone
else um but we were all hiding those
heat pads
up our backs and in our trousers and
then our pockets and
poor lily james just between every take
someone had to like throw a huge blanket
around her because she's just wearing
like
shorts and a shirt and sandals and stuff
so it was definitely
it was it was very cold yeah well
congratulations on the film i
learned so much i think i didn't even
know about this burial site so it was
fantastic